[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits amis bossoirs petit
nounours prends ton échelle et descend
vite chez nicolas et patronne est
d'accord pas trop je ne me fait pas
prier et l'europe ont l'échelle
je descends hop hop hop hop hop on peut
[Musique]
être à faire
bonsoir qu'est ce que vous faites les
enfants la mauvaise c'est mon front mais
fais attention avec des grosses pattes
ou ne casse pas que la lacrosse nicolas
deux mois torchon
alors nicolas tu as perdu ta non inutile
bas coûts
ben ouais je t'entends devrait bien y
aller dans la lune d'y aller dans la
lune non c'est bon non j'ai pas regardé
j'avais peur saint brieuc
j'avais mal aux tenues
venez la voir à la fenêtre ce tel bruit
oui parce qu'elle brille alloue les
enfants ou doudou
pas du tout tu pourrais nous raconte une
histoire où nous chanter une chanson le
petit marchand de sable va vous
enchanter une très jolie n'a couché ch
et à la lumière à vous à trop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lorsque nounours ah vient tout net 1
et qu'enfin il rejoint lens qu'il
remonte
de sa grande échelle que nous partons
dans le ciel
lorsque notre nuage
à un modèle et nicolas
ce
de leur côté sur leur petit oreiller
et je
a songé à tout l'est
enfin
que la lune fait
aimer
omer
vva
il y en a qui suce leur doigt d'autres
qui mord de leurs droits
laval une vie en l'air
elle aime bien les enfants
je
de quels bons conseils
et
mélissa noël
que leur dites r au secret touba
vraiment je ne
c'est ma
mais moi je sais
qu'à tous les menus
je
bibeau
[Musique]
football